who on the cast do you think would make
the best neighbor and the worst neighbor
I'm gonna let him go first because I'm
curious his answer I go to sleep early
so I'm not going to make a lot of noise
but then the kids during the day maybe
I'm not a great neighbor I
lacrosse
for sure Beth that would be the best Max
actually is mine like I think Max would
be the best neighbor too because he's
very considerate very kind he would like
come over and babysit if I needed him to
like I feel like he's a good dad
reluctantly but I would do it no you
would love you would love it yeah I know
but it would be I would make a whole
thing like you would have to be like oh
my God you're so great and I'd be like
and then secretly I'd be really excited
about it
um but Beth bakes in a very real way and
doesn't bring a lot of it to set which
is not great oh I know but I want to be
your neighbor
okay well everyone experiences some
awkward neighborhood moments uh but how
would we react in those moments we are
going to find out with a neighborhood
round of I'm awesome at being awkward
[Applause]
[Music]
awkward
[Applause]
here's what we do when I say go our
super random super computer will flip
through millions of awkward situations
choose one and we'll all have to say
what we do in that situation let's go by
all do you mean everyone here
it's gonna be a minute
okay you see your neighbor walk past his
garbage can and dump something
suspiciously heavy into yours what do
you do now I feel like this is a
different answer depending on where you
live because here trash is a you fill up
those trash cans you stay out of my
trash can because we fill them up and
you only get so many and they come back
and like in Texas it's not a big deal
but here it's a big deal I'm intense
about this answer I don't like
confrontation so I'd probably be like
dead body I don't know I'll like it's
okay as long as I don't have to get in a
fight with you I'm good I love that I
didn't go dead body I just meant like
there's not enough room
it says
suspiciously heavy so I was like oh I
went dead body immediately wow I'm
calling the cops yeah all ready for that
I'm just but I'm just coming I'm fresh
off of Evan Peters and Dahmer it's too
much for me I'm going right for the cops
I go I'm sorry uh Netflix scared me
uh there's someone putting something in
my garbage
I think I just feel like there's no room
in the end but
[Music]
accidentally leave their blinds open and
you oh and you actually make eye contact
with one of them as they're having
intimate neck in town
they make fun of me because I say naked
so what do you do when you see them the
next day I mean you know what I do
well done
well done I've done this you've done
this wait have you been the person you
see a naked one by accident
there was a rabbi it was when I was in
college and it was a Chabad house that I
lived next to you did it a rabbi
and and it um I just was rushing to get
to class one day yeah and I got out of
the shower and I forgot something in the
living room and I went out and I locked
eyes full on Rabbi like praying like in
his bedroom and he and it was like
it was like a sitcom moment for sure wow
but I've never done it again I'm very
conscious of my I'm not if you look in
my house and see something that's your
problem
oh I like that yeah that's my house yeah
Rabbi it was my house my house you close
your blinds yeah yeah you can't pray the
naked away yeah
what about you wait have you ever have
you ever caught what would you do what
would you do no I I had a similar I'm
I'm a little stuck on what's what
intimate naked intimate naked time is
and you know it into it
so I so I see so I
I just don't believe that's ever gonna
happen then I'm going to look in the I'm
going to look in the window I'm gonna
I'm gonna make eye contact with two
people that are having are you serious
that's never happened y'all like have
you ever lived in a city yeah like or in
a hotel in like New York I think this
has happened like a few times to me
where I've been like oh my god well done
well done
like yeah that's totally happened I'm
rooting for you well I'm I'm I'm excited
to experience it for the first time I
don't know what I do or maybe you'll be
the one doing
oh congratulations I'm gonna call Tessa
congratulations
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]